as kids head back to school many
families are feeling the bite of
inflation in a new way the national
retail federation says that families
with students in k through 12 can expect
to spend an average of 864
on school supplies this year and that is
168 dollars more than in 2019. adriana
diaz is in chicago for us and she's
looking at strategies that can help
people save on that big number adriana
good morning
good morning tony as lots of parents can
already tell this back to school season
is one of the most expensive on record
to give you a sense according to
dataweave which tracks consumer pricing
notebooks and folders are up the most
nearly 32 percent more expensive than
last year and backpacks are up 12
percent costing roughly 70 dollars on
average that is driving parents to get
creative this back-to-school season
this is back to school excitement and
these chicago kids are getting free
school supplies to get ready
the nonprofit back to school america
gave out more than 8 thousand supply
kits wednesday people are telling me
that they've lost their jobs their home
situation has changed they've lost their
home ceo matt kurtzman says the need for
the kits and the cost to create them has
never been greater what single product
has gone up most in price
paper is the one product that is costing
us the most money that's one reason
their price for supplies has jumped 10
percent the prices have increased
ridiculous
janila costing whose daughter is about
to start first grade says there's also
sticker shock in stores for a few school
supplies you're easily going to spend
around 70 dollars or something is this
the most expensive back to school season
you've seen it is for the parents and
the teachers kelly zouza owns the
classmate a school supply store and she
says she can barely keep up with price
hikes from suppliers
it's hard because a lot of the companies
have increased their prices alone in
this calendar year five times why are
things like paper more expensive what's
happening is through the pandemic they
shut down a lot of the mills and so now
there's a shortage if parents choose to
go to one big store without the planning
first i think they're leaving enough
money on the table for it to matter
kelly glass writes about parenting for
the website kindred by parents should
parents be getting in the car and going
back to school shopping in person or
should they be ordering things online
that then gets shipped to them a mixture
of both right
i do what i call pre-shopping online
seeing what deals the stores have but
also checking inventory because what we
don't want to be doing is hopping around
from store to store and wasting that gas
money and wasting that gas because it's
expensive she also suggests checking
apps that offer coupons or cash back on
purchases and considering generic brands
also be strategic maybe there's a
backpack brand that cost more than other
brands but it comes with a lifetime
guarantee
another idea connecting with nonprofits
that might be giving away supplies how
much does getting free supplies help
especially at a time like this it helps
a lot especially because
there's other things i could be paying
for what do you think about your
supplies
and how excited are you to start first
grade
she was so cute kelly glass who gave us
all those suggestions says there is one
key thing parents should not do and that
is stress she says try to make this a
positive and exciting experience to set
the tone for your kids this school year
tony
okay a lot of people saying i'll try but
168 dollars in additional spending
because of inflation that hurts a bit uh
adriana those are good tips though it'll
save people some money uh for sure thank
you very much easier said than done not
to be stressed don't you remember the
guys when you were six you were so
excited about that first day of school
your little pencils and your crayons and
the little black and white folder you
get your lunch box you know you can
lunchbox lunch box
the happy sound of the velcro and the
chopper packer